what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so continuing on with superior
spider-man we're officially into the
story without Peter Parker and it's
actually kind of cool here I mean Peter
Parker is cool and everything but the
idea of doing a story where Doctor
Octopus takes over the body of Peter
Parker it's something that I'd like to
see focused on strictly as him without
influence from Peter Parker and Dan
Slott gives us that I mean this first
issue is actually called independence
you know independence day because he's
basically free of the control of Peter
Parker at least the influence of Peter
Parker now the cool thing about this is
it allows Dan Slott to set the stage for
everything in all-new all-different
amazing spider-man because remember you
have superior spider-man the whole run
33 issues you've got spider-verse which
spider-verse doesn't wasn't really
necessary it's kind of a cool story but
it's not really necessary by any
standard of measure and it's almost
completely and totally self-contained
and then you have two story arcs for
Amazing Spiderman and then all-new
all-different marvel happens so again
it's pretty cool in terms of how all
this just segues directly into the
current run of amazing spider-man under
Dan Slott clothes as fiercely and all
that kind of good stuff
but what this does is it shows us how
streamlined Doc Ock is made spider-man's
life remember he's got all these little
spider eyes that are walking around well
because of that they literally keep an
eye on New York and tell him everything
that's happening and so when he wakes up
in the morning he gets daily briefings
on what's happening what villains are
fighting one another which ones are
worth their attention and which ones
aren't now the funny thing about this is
Doc Ock talks about how in this
circumstance Peter Parker would have
just thrown on the spider-man costume
and would have just jumped into the fray
because of this he says I'm not going to
take that role instead I'm going to let
them deplete their ranks I'm gonna let
them fight each other to the point that
they can't fight anymore and I'm going
to go in and I'm going to take things
over it's classic
Napoleon Bonaparte that's really what it
is Napoleon Bonaparte was well known for
that
go into countries star civil wars when
after we guess conquer them it's the
smartest way to conduct yourself in
terms of taking over a hostile entity
and that's exactly what he does here
he's like look if I wanted to feed these
guys I could go in and just fight them
all but the problem is I may or may not
win and it would just be a waste of time
what I can do is just let them keep
fighting each other into the point that
their forces are to the point of
exhaustion when that happens I'll go in
and just take everybody over and that's
exactly what happens like nobody does he
goes in and of course attacks like our
man you know and a handful of others to
Billy the other thing that I want to
point out here is how strong
spider-man is when I was going through
spider-man number seven number 700 we
were going through like you know die
anguish and suicide run and all those
stories that led up to superior
spider-man one of the things that I
wanted to hold off on talking about was
the idea of how strong spider-man is now
Sal aware comic pop has done several
videos on my channel which you'll find
down in the description but we run over
spider-man stuff and then South one of
the four most knowledgeable people about
spider-man that I've ever met it's
literally his bread and butter like it's
crazy how knowledgeable he is about
spider-man but historically speaking
there's been references to Peter Parker
pulling his punches but amazing
spider-man numbers number 700 Doctor
Octopus confirmed that and that's a
significant of those kind of things in
color books it's one thing for a
character to say I'm really powerful
it's another for other characters to say
yes they are really powerful to confirm
it by virtue of another character gives
it a little more substance now again
it's just whatever the writers want it
to be and so take it for what it is but
the fact remains here that with Doctor
Octopus fighting against scorpion in
superior spider-man
I'm sorry enough amazing spider-man
number number 700 he punched him in the
jaw so hard that he knocked his jaw and
that's when Doctor Octopus realized how
strong Peter Parker is and that s
spider-man he basically been pulling his
punches the entire time now the reason
why that was significant is because what
it means is going forward in this story
the stories before as part of superior
spider-man
if the Doc Ock had to recognize how easy
it would be for him to kill foes
there's one of the first things that the
Peter Parker started to realize in the
alternate universe it's the first thing
he realized to his detriment when he
killed a person so because this is
really kind of cool to see it all unfold
but again one of the other things going
on behind the scenes here is the return
of Norman Osborn really as the Green
Goblin I'll keep in mind Norman Osborn
has and always will be a spider-man
villain but he had a lot of a lot of you
know really promotion and a lot of
exposure to the larger cover book
community and Marvel went during the
events of a Dark Reign when he became
the director of shield now I don't know
what was going on behind the scenes I'm
Malin find any interviews to verify but
I don't know anything going on behind
the scenes in terms of whether or not
this was all design the whole Dark Reign
story was all designed to bolster the
reputation on Norman Osborn so that when
goblin nation happened then it would be
a lot more interesting I don't really
know that's the case or not
the only thing that I can really guess
here is that because of the fact that
Norman Osborn is essentially going to
hem himself as the Goblin King you know
going I guess really as part of lead up
to goblin nation then it was just really
part of a scheme to kind of reinvigorate
this character but again this could
entirely be self-contained too if it
just via the dance lie didn't care
anything about Dark Reign and it just
said you know what we're going to revamp
the Osborn and we're going to make him a
goblin King instead of the Green Goblin
I have no real idea here but the fact
remains that switching back over to doc
ock is spider-man again a lot of this
deals with him and his personal
relationships it was actually funny
watching him talk to people because of
the fact they're usually just talks down
to them and it's not like I mean I don't
think it's plenty to talk down to people
but it's funny in terms of how he does
it and dissented he's talking to the
professor you know the press report is
porous pieces and he's like man this
guy's a buffoon and he talks to him that
way like he literally finishes his test
takes it over hands it in and says don't
bother worrying about it i H the whole
thing you don't have to check it but you
can if you want but if you did you just
be wasting your time so it's it's funny
they kind of see him interacting that
way but again yeah with regards to
Goblin King bolstering his ranks he's
basically grabbing all these different
individuals these different henchmen
part of these small-time criminals or
just petty thieves or what-have-you and
having them operate as part of his
scheme in order to essentially try to
take over New York now again a lot of
this is leading up to goblin nation so
it's just these pages here and there you
know where some small things happen
regards to to the green Goblin's but
what is them happening here if some of
these goblins attack Mary Jane Watson
nightclub this whole attack coincides
with dinner that a Spider Man is having
with Anna Maria and I remember Anna
Maria is part of all-new all-different
marvel she's a woman of a diminutive
size but she's also really interesting
and the reason why is because when her
being as intelligent as she is she
doesn't really cook using conventional
methods and in fact what she's doing is
she's making a carbonated sorbet using
dry ice but it's really cool because
they're basically making ice cream now
of course this is great in and of itself
because ice cream isn't anytime you like
you can have ice cream any time that's
one of the great things I love about ice
cream my personal favorite is cookies
and cream I will know what your personal
favorite is I love cookies and cream
pretty Lindsey cream is a bad chocolate
chip ice cream is terrible chocolate
mint is even worse but I love cookies
and cream but what this does is it sets
the stage for romance between the two of
them and the reason why is because when
the dry ice is dropped you know of
course
spider-man reaches in grabs it and just
kind of lets it go realizing you know
that it hurts him but annamaria kind of
patches them up and the two of them
share a kiss now this is
because with the character of annamaria
what she's going to do is begin the
process of transitioning Doctor Octopus
away from being a bad guy and in fact
almost the entirety of his motivation
with regards to you know all-new
all-different marvel and all stuff is
going to be rooted in his love for
annamaria so that's the coolest thing
about this one of things like that I
really dig about that but again it's
also Dan Slott messing with the idea of
Mary Jane Watson finding love of her own
when the entire incident was a the
attack on her nightclub the resulting
fire and so on is met by a fire
department and she comes across a guy
named Pedro so again the oh damn fires
kind of 20 where this notion of the two
of them going their own separate ways I
mean it's already established at this
point by virtually things that he's
written into the story that you know
superior spider-man and Mary Jane Watson
are never going to get together but the
other half of this is again the way the
entire spider-man process has been
streamlined the fire department showing
up at Mary Jane Watson severed Mary Jo
Martha's business came by way of
superior spider-man because the fact
that he's aware of everything that's
been going on with the city in his mind
he was arguing well why not have my own
life and keep the city safe and that's
exactly what he did when the when the
attack happened when the fire broke out
he basically had the fire department
notified and they responded now of
course the bigger question to ask here
is what would Peter Parker have done and
Peter Parker would have arrived he would
have left
Anna Maria he would have arrived on the
scene and the reason why is because he
wouldn't know whether or not people were
going to die in the fire and that's one
of the issues with regards to superior
spider-man in terms of how he views
himself as spider-man me it's no secret
by now he's a much darker character and
because of his willingness to kill
something that will actually see yet
again I hear in this story in his mind
you know the needs of the many outweigh
the needs of the few so sure one person
might die in that fire but if seven
people are saved well then that's just
the way it goes and so again it's kind
of a darker road to take for us
character but it's one of the reasons
that I kind of find a little refreshing
here man you know Peter Parker
spider-man is the spider-man it'll
always be that way but for me Doctor
Octopus in superior spider-man makes a
little more interesting makes a little
more you know a little more visceral in
terms of how somebody would his mind
would operate in a position like that
now force at this point we transition
over to Jo and Jameson with the
execution of Spider Slayer now keep in
mind we talked about this when we first
started spider-man big time we had
spires later
I'm sorry spiders later
I was there Smythe who again had
basically attacked spider-man but it
resulted in the death of Marla Jameson J
John Jameson's wife and so because of
this Alastair Smythe is getting ready to
undergo execution but the khalsa
spider-man comes by way of the fact that
J John Jameson believes that that Smythe
is going to have some contingency plan
in place in order to allow him to break
free now of course all of this is taking
place on the raft which is a maximum
security prison for supervillains really
like the rats had his biggest claim to
fame when electro engineered a mass
breakout at the start of New Avengers
when Brian Michael Bendis first took
over the title really when the title was
first launched to be honest and he was
this inaugural story if the RAF which is
really really cool and after that it was
who is the century like no Avenger is
really good for a little while and it is
kind of dropped off but it was pretty
solid you know in the beginning uh but
the fact remains here that the
relationships between superior
spider-man and all the other people that
he knows are predicated on how he views
himself in relation to them and so
there's a lot of arrogance there's a lot
of not really cruelty but there's a lot
of the belief that he's simply better
than they are just by virtue of his
intelligence now the other half of this
is that this is Doctor Octopus in the
body of Peter Parker which means that
with Alastair Smith getting ready to
undergo his execution that basically his
little spider the spider Slayer BOTS
immediately infiltrate the place and
start ripping things up but Doctor
Octopus was ready for it all and that's
why I say I think he's better than Peter
Parker because Peter Parker basically
flies by the seat of his pants as
spider-man now for Peter Parker fans
that's the endearing part of it that's
the reason why they love it it's because
of the fact that you never know what's
going to happen he doesn't even know
what's going to happen he's quick on his
toes he has to think fast he jumps into
a situation uses his intelligence
combined with his spider sense and his
abilities in order to try to get the
situation to bend to his favorite with
Doctor Octopus it's a lot more
methodical it's a lot more planning but
I would say it's also a much better
implementation of spider-man I mean
let's say for example the Peter Parker
took the steps mr. Peter spider-man did
where he basically has spider BOTS all
throughout the city
imagine how much safer in New York would
be with Peter Parker using that method
but of course again superior spotting
there was one that came up with it to
basically streamline the process now in
truth this is really dance la to me as
you know you kind of continue to this
fight this is really Dan Slott basically
saying hey look this is the basis behind
what will
an all-new all-different marvel this
spider-man process was streamlined
because superior spider-man made it so
and so what it meant was that when Peter
Parker finally got his body back he
benefited from all the work of superior
spider-man that's when the reasons why
it's so cool but again Doc Ock basically
cuts off almost every single route of
escape for Alastair Smith but the other
half of this is that with superior
spider-man having you know destroyed the
jaw of scorpion you know having fought
off against guys you know like vulture
and so on what this does is it sets the
stage for them gaining their own revenge
and is basically this idea that his own
ghosts are coming back on him now this
is really just kind of you know dance
flops darkness in there for the sake of
having in there it's not bad it's just
kind of cool to see but it's really more
of a message about consequence it's more
of a message about the fact that
whenever it is that the Doc Ock goes
through an action superior spider-man
and x-men civ there will be fall back
there will be splash or there will be
consequences for his actions and so of
course the cool thing about this is that
you know one of the box basically
appears so I ignore winters who works
literally vehicle I J jonah jameson most
of these individuals who were there to
observe the execution and if since just
kind of watched everything go awry and
superior spider-man shows up with a
pre-recorded message essentially saying
look I've planned for this I figured
this was going to happen I'm going to
create a bubble that's going to keep you
protected
do not leave or you will put yourself in
danger which of course Jay jonah Jameson
leaves because jenna jameson but I would
also say this is probably one of the
best moments of his character and reason
why is because with superior spider-man
and Alastair Smythe fighting one another
basically Jo Jameson shows up in a
guards outfit and manages to offer a
distraction but of course in the
meantime you know we really have
spider-man dealing with like you know
scorpion and dealing with vulture and so
on you know anything but I'll hold off
his only a means able to do pretty well
but then we also have doc Connors being
freed from itself when Alistair Smythe
takes power down to the to the facility
now keep in mind we talked about about
Doc Connor to be historically speaking
lizards always just been a villain of
spider-man he was driven more by like
impulse and instinct and you know his
desire to kill spider-man more so than
anything else but we had talked during
real really during big Tom in the events
leading up to superior spider-man that
Doc Connors the Connors persona had
basically taken over it had been quite
some time since he was the you know the
notable villain that we'd all know
who just kind of ripped things up
instead you know he was very much
himself and so where he would be freed
and we would think he would join in the
fray against superior spider-man he
actually doesn't instead he basically
fights as a good guy because it is doc
Connors fighting you know with the doc
Connors mind and so because of this in
the minor superior spider-man Alistair
Smythe represents just incorrigibility
the fact that Smythe will not stop until
he kills J jonah Jameson basically
continues his campaign of eliminating
everybody that he simply just doesn't
like or that has harmed him in some form
or fashion and so we end up having
scorpion attempting to attack J jonah
Jameson we I'm having doc Connors jump
into the fray now missiles actually
really really cool to see and the reason
why was because when it comes to the
different foes of spider-man spider-man
has some of the most recognizable
villains and coming book coming pop made
a really good point about that during an
episode of the weekly cool about how
spider-man has some of the most notable
villains in the realm of comic books I
mean I would say that like Doctor
Octopus you know scorpion venom carnage
those are some of the most popular
villains to have ever appeared I mean
you have guys like Lex Luthor you know
in Darkseid who are always going to be
you know at the very very top you know
you've got guys like the Joker who is
who is at the very top if you look at
almost every single list of the most
popular villains who ever existed but
spider-man always has a very popular
rogues gallery the difference here is
this is not Peter Parker facing off
against these guys this is Doctor
Octopus but to have doc Connors aligned
himself with Jay jonah Jameson fighting
against the scorpion it's a cool thing
it's actually a really interesting turn
of events to see I feel because of this
ill essentially doc Connors overpowers
scorpion in the extreme I mean there's
really no contest here he absolutely
wrecks n't and the reason why is because
it's just so much organic strength and
lizard himself and so it's really kind
of a funny situation to see but the fact
remains here you know jumping back over
to two superior spider-man because the
fact that these bots are essentially
being made to fail because they're being
engineered and being shut down what it
means is that the various abilities of
these you know different guys are
effectively going away vultures going
back to being a blind guy you know so on
and so forth they're not nearly as
capable as they were a second ago so
again with everything effectively having
come to an end with them all having been
defeated Alastair Smyth makes one
last-ditch effort to try to destroy
superior spider-man but interest he's
fighting on fumes and he's got he's
really got nothing
left hand so superior spider-man
essentially takes him out and kills him
any basically says look where Alistair
Smythe intended to basically switch
bodies with superior spider-man in the
same way the Doctor Octopus switched
bodies with Peter Parker Doc Ock says no
that's the first thing that any villain
facing off against me would try to do is
take over my body if they have any
measure of intelligence he says I
planned for that but then what he also
does is in his dying moments superior
spider-man reveals that he's actually
Doc Ock to Alastair Smythe and so again
basically bringing his body back up and
simply saying this guy is dead he's not
going to bother us anymore what he does
is on the way back to the island Peter
spider-man reveals to J John Jameson
that he had recorded a conversation
between the two of them and in this
conversation J jonah Jameson had stated
look Alastair Smythe was supposed to be
here for his execution I want you to
make sure that happened when superior
spider-man asked the question are you
asking me to kill Alistair Smythe jgo
jameson more or less said yes and so
because the fact that this conversation
was recorded what is up happening in
superior spider-man says you're the
mayor of New York you're going to give
me the rap you're going to shut it down
and you're going to give it to me if you
don't I'm going to issue this broadcast
out to the world and everybody is going
to see that the mayor of New York City J
jonah Jameson had sanctioned the murder
of a villain and so again let's
basically kind of set things back to two
familiarity and the J jonah Jameson is
like I hate you again spider-man I hate
you now I absolutely despise you now
like you are you're a terrible thing but
the reason why superior spider-man did
this is because of the fact that what
the raft is simply having its doors
closed and him taking over it doesn't
give JJ Jameson or anybody any time to
take out everything that's in there and
so essentially you have superior
spider-man with access to military-grade
technology and weapons and so again what
it does is it allows him to up the ante
in terms of his role as spider-man and
move things in the direction of taking
even more of a militaristic approach
then he previously has in the story so
far but with that being said guys we're
going to bring this video to an end if
you are new here to come as explained
make sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the rockwork if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like again I love it superior spider-man
it's such a different take on what we're
used to like I love I love the nature of
this story
I'm really
we're covering them because all this was
going to dead end into you know shortly
after the release of Amazing Spiderman
so like that movie will come out and
hopefully my videos will serve as a way
for anybody who's interested in
spider-man to catch up on the whole
mythos with everything leading up to
right now
but anyway guys I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Applause]